مره اخرى يتحرك الشارع الفرنسي ضد مشروع
اصلاح نظام التقاعد
هذه المره على التعبئه الطابع الشبان
هؤلاء يخشونه
وضعهم الهش ويسد الافاق امامهم
[موسيقى]
عن نفسي ايضا
على العمل حتى سن الخامسه والستين واظن ان
لا احد سيكون في صحه جيده عندما يتقاعد في
ذلك السن
اللافتات والشعارات ترجمه غضب المحتجين
على سياسه الرئيس مانويل ماكرون
الاجتماعيه
وقد لحظ في هذه المظاهره حضور لافته
لاسحاب السترات الصفراء الذين زعزعوا
الفتره الاولى للرئيس مكرون
اصحاب السترات الصفراء كانوا دائما
موجودين دخلوا بيوتهم لانه في الديمقراطيه
الفرنسيه عندما لا تكون راضيا يفقعون عينك
نحن هنا لمواصله نضالنا وهذا استفتاء على
سياسه مكرون
هدوم فيك الكبرى
حزب فرنسا الابيه الخصم السياسي لمكرون
واشد معارضيه ويبدو انه كسب الرهان من
خلال هذه المظاهره لكي يكون احد قاده
تحريك الشارع ضد سياسه الحكومه
الاصلاح لانه غير عادل ومبني على الاكاذيب
نعرف جيدا انه لاعز في نظام التقاعد وكل
ما يريده مكرون وهو تاخيره سن التقاعد لكي
يحصلوا على علاوه منخفضه ولكي يمول فقط
صناديق التقاعدي الخاصه
من حزب فرنسا الابيه ضد التغيرات التي
تريده السلطات ادخالها على النظام التقاعد
وخصوصا ارجاؤه الى سن الرابعه والستين
وترى في ذلك سياسه غير اجتماعيه الا ان
الحكومه لا تبدو حتى الان مستعده للتراجع
اما تسميه اصلاحها نور الدين بوزيان
الجزيره باريس